bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi
l'aboutissement du grand projet de
jacques chirac à paris onze ans après sa
conception le président de la république
a inauguré le musée du quai branly
immense bâtiment dédié aux arts premiers
en présence de kofi annan et de très
nombreuses personnalités
un vif incident à l'assemblée dominique
de villepin accusé françois hollande de
lâcheté devant la fureur des députés
socialistes la séance a dû être
suspendue la gauche réclame des excuses
et le départ du premier ministre
françois bayrou demande des élections
anticipées les réquisitions au procès de
la catastrophe du mont sainte odile en
le procureur demande la condamnation à
de la prison avec sursis de trois
anciens cadres de l'aviation civile
d'airbus d'air à terre et d'un
contrôleur aérien et la relaxe des deux
autres prévenus
la sécurité routière le gouvernement
veut maintenant lutter contre le
téléphone portable au volant
une campagne est lancée avec la
collaboration des opérateurs le nombre
de conducteurs pris en faute a augmenté
de 10% l'an passé nouvelle épreuve pour
les états unis en irak les corps des
deux soldats enlevés la semaine dernière
ont été retrouvés ils ont été torturé et
égorgé par ailleurs le japon a décidé
officiellement de retirer ses troupes du
pays d'ici cinq semaines
enfin la coupe du monde en allemagne
l'allemagne qui a impressionné à nouveau
en dominant l'équateur 3 0 trois
victoires en trois matches l'équipe de
france elle a repris l'entraînement
raymond domenech conteste de toute
mésentente avec zinedine zidane
c'est le premier grand musée à sortir de
terre en france depuis près de 30 ans le
bâtiment du quai branly à deux pas de la
tour eiffel a donc été inauguré en
grande pompe par jacques chirac
le projet vous le savez est consacré aux
arts premiers il lui tenait
particulièrement à coeur c'est lui qui
l'avait lancé et c'est aussi lui qui a
joué le guide pour ses invités de marque
véronique saint-élie francis forget
disons de travaux pour le musée du quai
branly dix ans pour faire battre en
plein paris le coeur des civilisations
oublier parfois méprisé d'afrique d'asie
d'océanie et d'amérique
jacques chirac apprécie en connaisseur
c'est pour lui l'aboutissement d'une
passion qu'il cultive depuis toujours et
d'une conviction aussi il n'existe pas
plus de hiérarchie des cultures et des
hiérarchies des peuples autour du
président de la république les premiers
ministres d'aujourd'hui et bières
rendent hommage à ces formes d'armes
première non par primitive mais première
au projet dans la pénombre les trésors
des quatre continents masqué fétiche
d'afrique statues en granit de polynésie
chef inuits parure indienne étoffe
mongols rigoberta menchu prix nobel de
la paix explique la culture
guatémaltèque kofi annan le secrétaire
général des nations unies selles dures
canada puis dans le grand amphithéâtre
où travailleront plus tard étudiants et
chercheurs les personnalités de tous
bords se bousculent
en montrant qu'il existe d'autres
manières d'agir et de penser d'autres
relations entre les êtres
d'autres rapports au monde le musée du
quai branly proclame qu'aucun peuple
aucune nation aucune civilisation
n'épuise ne résume le génie humain et
c'est seulement dans leur expression
toujours renouvelé que s'entrevoit
l'universel qui nous rassemble en cette
fin de mandat difficile et jacques
chirac espère bien avec ce musée faire
de l'ouverture au monde sa marque de
fabrique
il reconnaît aussi que cela serait pour
lui un grand honneur
si l'on donné son nom au musée jacques
chirac il n'est pas le premier a
souhaité imprimer sa marque dans la
capitale depuis georges pompidou tous
les présidents de la vème république ont
voulu laisser une trace c'est quasiment
devenu une tradition arnaud boutet
mathias second sous la vème république
il lance la dynastie des président
bâtisseur georges pompidou voulait un
musée d'art moderne
la maquette du projet provoque un
premier choc elle est freinée par ici je
crois qu'on a besoin d'autre chose que
de musée c'est trop compliqué pour moi
c'est une boîte et prison j'entends pad
avant cela la cinquième de beethoven
dedans ou le sacre du printemps
pompidou leur avant la fin des travaux
son successeur achève ce chantier de
verre et d'acier
le centre beaubourg est enfin inauguré
après avoir été très menacé était tout à
fait contre ce genre d'architecturé et
la file de la supprimer
c'est chirac plus classique
valéry giscard d'estaing transforme la
gare d'orsay en musée mais une fois de
plus un autre président coupe le ruban
giscard fait partie des invités françois
mitterrand érige la pyramide du louvre
dans la cour napoléon il laisse son
empreinte à grands coups de truelle
l'opéra bastille l'arche de la défense
la grande bibliothèque
les grands travaux symbolise le fait du
prince on se dit qu'il ya quand même
quelque chose d'un peu pharaonique est
ce qu'il n'ya pas sans quelques je peux
dire en labour ou diderot l'a beaucoup
dit c'est facile pour un président de
dire up l'inférence eu des grands
travaux et toc j'ai l'argent c'est
facile ou pas très bon vous êtes patron
c'est pourtant lui qui a débloqué les
fonds dans cette frénésie constructive
un homme se distingue le général de
gaulle il n'a fait construire qu'un seul
bâtiment la maison de la radio
la politique a été si forte avec unique
n'avait pas prendre vos propres besoins
d'un monument de gaulle considéré qu'il
était l'histoire les autres présidents
ont tous choisi la culture pour laisser
une trace et le musée du quai branly
rappelons le ouvrira ses portes au
public vendredi
ce n'est plus une bourrasque c'est une
tempête politique qui a secoué
l'assemblée nationale cet après midi au
départ il y à un réquisitoire de
françois hollande contre dominique de
villepin
le premier ministre en difficulté depuis
plusieurs mois est sorti de ses gonds
il a accusé le numéro un socialiste de
l'acheter alexandre kara jean-marc
nouknouk pas de confiance dans le pays
pas de conscience dans la majorité pas
de confiance dans la presse
dans une démocratie digne de ce nom le
chef de l'état où le parlement aurait
mis fin à cette situation mais nous
sommes dans le régime de
l'irresponsabilité je dénonce monsieur
hollande
la facilité et je dirais même en vous
regardant la lâcheté la htm ou s'il y a
dans votre attitude
j'en organisé ou la lâcheté en ces mots
tendres le don de l'excavation l'ordre
il y a trois contradiction dans ce cas
vous avez ni 3 contradictions
la première sur la politique
industrielle
von ah oui jamais assumé arrêté
achetez-vous et de relever ce défi merci
monsieur hollande aller
calais
monsieur hollande je vous en prie je
boude après monsieur hollande veut
monsieur lord rogers co monsieur
cacophonie succès de l'interruption de
séance en sorte qu'on les centristes il
n'ya désormais qu'un seul scénario
possible
on n'est qu'avec d'entendre m'acheter un
show c'est une décomposition et de cette
composition on devrait sortir par les
élections
seuls quelques rares villepiniste
viennent défendre le premier ministre et
encore avec une paix fragile et faible
parce que ça fait six mois qu'il est
l'objet de ces ateliers beauté je le dis
très sincèrement il a réagi aujourd'hui
en novembre premier ministre eh bien on
peut le lui reprocher et on peut
également comprendre mais dans les rangs
de l'ump beaucoup ne cherche plus à
sauver les apparences
moi en tant que député je suis pas fier
de ce que j'ai vécu là voilà donc c'est
parti
il faut que le premier ministre son âne
y voilà ce soir les socialistes menace
si dominique de villepin ne présente pas
ses excuses
ils boycotteront les séances de
questions au gouvernement à propos de
politique encore en ce qui concerne
françois bayrou le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel a finalement renoncé à
comptabiliser son temps de parole dans
celui de l'opposition il sera
neutralisée ne comptera donc ni pour un
camp ni pour l'autre et puis toujours à
propos de la politique la grève
organisée à edf et gdf contre la fusion
à gaz de france suez a été relativement
peu suivis entre 10 et 14% de grévistes
à paris la manifestation a rassemblé
entre 700 et 3000 personnes selon les
sources
il faut noter aussi que les syndicats du
groupe suez eux avaient organisé un
pique nique place des invalides en
faveur de la fusion avec gaz de france
justice la science au secours des
enquêteurs une affaire est sans doute
sur le point d'être résolu
dix neuf ans après grâce aux dernières
avancées
un sapeur pompier a été confondu pour un
viol et un meurtre commis près d'avignon
en 1987 son adn avait été prélevé
récemment dans un tout autre dossier
sophie rodier benoît jourdan gisait le
crosnier attendait ce jour depuis 18 ans
et demi la justice vient de lui
apprendre que le meurtrier présumé de sa
fille a probablement été confondu
aujourd'hui c'est déjà un grand coup de
massue que j'ai reçus mais soulagement
dans la mesure où je sais que déjà il va
pas recommencer et 18 ans et demi de
doutes
aujourd'hui j'ai un visage et nous en
1987 evelyne boucher 16 ans est enlevé à
la sortie du lycée
son corps est retrouvé le lendemain de
sa disparition elle a été violée puis
étranglée
l'enquète va durer des années 500
suspects sont interrogés sans résultat
jusqu'à mars 2004 un pompier condamné à
la suite d'une bagarre subit alors un
prélèvement adn comme le permet
désormais la loi l'échantillon est
transmis au fichier des empreintes
génétiques puis comparé à celui retrouvé
sur evelyne boucher en 1987
les experts sont formels les deux adn
concordent
l'identification formelle quasi formelle
à 99 9% sur plusieurs barker entre la
personne concernée et les traces qu'ils
ont été prélevés sur le corps de la
jeune evelyn boucherie en garde à vue le
suspect clame son innocence son avocat
met en doute la fiabilité des analyses
ce que je vais devoir d'une manière très
précise c'est les conditions dans
lesquelles l'adn a été collecté il a 19
ans parce que la preuve adn
aujourd'hui si elle est irréfutable elle
était loin et est réfutable
vingt ans en arrière au terme de sa
garde à vue le suspect devrait être
transféré devant un juge et probablement
mise en examen justice encore en bref le
mercenaire bob dénard 77 ans a été
condamné par le tribunal de paris à cinq
ans de prison avec sursis et était jugé
pour sa participation aux côtés de 26
autres personnes à une tentative de coup
d'état aux comores il ya un peu plus de
dix ans le procès de la catastrophe
aérienne du mont sainte-odile qui avait
fait 87 morts touche à sa fin le parquet
vient de rendre ses réquisitions il
demande la condamnation un des peines
symboliques du constructeur airbus du
contrôle aérien et de la compagnie air
inter le détail de ces réquisitions avec
christine boss et nicolas frehner à
colmar bernard ziegler le concepteur de
l'a320 a perdu de sa superbe
celui qui disait avec force arrogance
pour certains avoir conçu l'avion le
plus sûr du monde se voit reprocher une
ergonomie de tableau de bord plus qu'un
parfaite un même bouton pour
sélectionner deux modes de des sens
différents des écrans illisible cela a
favorisé la confusion de l'équipage qui
descendra quatre fois plus vite que la
normale
le procureur a requis 1 an avec sursis à
l'encontre de bernard ziegler lafourcade
êtes une faune beaucoup plus grave
et d'ailleurs je dirais qu'il n'ya
aucune faute aucune faute ni caractérisé
n'est autre qui puisse être imputables à
monsieur ziegler deuxième grand fautif
le gp w s ou en larmes de proximité de
st c'est l'absence de cet équipement sur
les avions d'air inter en 1992 qui
constitue selon le procureur une faute
caractérisée même imparfaite cette
alarme qui somme lorsque l'avion descend
trop bas aurait probablement permis
d'éviter le crash
le procureur a requis 1 an avec sursis à
l'encontre d'un dirigeant dès 20h et
d'un responsable de l'aviation civile
enfin neuf mois avec sursis ont été
requis à l'encontre du contrôleur aérien
poursuivi pour des erreurs de guidage
des réquisitions décevante pour les
parties civiles
nous sommes très déçus que ça soit des
peines symboliques ça c'est tout à fait
ce n'est pas 14 a qui vont donner cette
cette situation
le procureur le reconnaît il s'agit de
peines symboliques probablement pas à la
hauteur du préjudice subi par les
nombreuses familles de victimes
en tout état de cause il faudra attendre
le 15 octobre pour connaître le délibéré
de ses huit semaines de procès la
présentation de la promotion annuelle
des commissaires formé à l'école de
police le ministre de l'intérieur
nicolas sarkozy s'est rendu pour
l'occasion à saint cyr au mont d'or
la police qui depuis une dizaine
d'années veut diversifier son
recrutement en clair accueillir dans ses
rangs plus d'enfants d'immigrés voici
l'exemple de betty sem bas âge elle est
d'origine marocaine
elle a 26 ans elle est issue d'un
quartier modeste et pour elle c'est une
nouvelle vie qui a commencé même si ça
n'est pas toujours simple
l'une de nos équipes a passé plusieurs
jours à ses côtés reportage karine
comazzi lionel langlade
cette femme est en état d'ébriété et
c'est l'adjointe de sécurité qui en
prend pour son grade
une insulte en arabe parce qu'outre le
fait d'être bird 6 mba jean faisant que
bleu l'autorité la dame interpellé a eu
du mal à s'y retrouver
comme elle 10% des policiers du
département sont issus de l'immigration
un choix politique la police
d'aujourd'hui doit mieux refléter la
population gare rer de torcy heures de
pointe vous faites contre les agressions
contrôler un problème d'éthique et la
commissaire est indulgente et jeune
fille sont surpris qu'elle ait d'autres
l'immigration est abordé le parler mais
pour la jeune femme être policière issus
de l'immigration n'autorisent aucune
concession étrangères après sa facile
certaines choses quand il faut leur
parler quand les gens ils savent pas
parler en arabe comme on a déjà eu le
cas d'une personne qui avait près de
papier savait pas parler français moi je
mettrais à langue arabe
je discute avec elle et je traduis tout
au fur et à mesure pour que mes
collègues ne sont pas mis de côté ça
fasse pas un dialogue entre deux
représentent la force publique que ce
soit 10 m on voit égaux dans l'uniforme
pas dans le parcours il ya quatre ans
encore les policiers arrêtaient de
l'autre côté de la barrière du côté de
la galère deux fois
pour nourrir sa petite fille la jeune
policière a répondu à une annonce
cherche adjointe de sécurité pas de
diplôme peu de choix
habitué à parer les coups elle sera
policiers il ya quelques semaines en
tête rigoler c'est un système mieux les
rares chili à des ordres pour respecter
pas mal de trucs on va jeter en 10
rebelles parce que tout ça ça me
connaissez pas je vais recommander que
ça va bien ça va poser de sa vie d'avant
elle n'a gardé que deux amis des lilas
et sabrina les celle pour qui gardien de
la paix est un métier comme un autre
les autres l'ont laissé tomber avec moi
parce que j'étais enfin parce que je
porte du bus alors qu' il y a dix ans
petit sam barrage était la première
femme au cours de kick boxing
son professeur était fier comme il est
aujourd'hui de sa policiers et s'est
toujours battu contre tout ce qui était
injuste donc je pensais pas si c'est
logique quand même une bonne rencontre
au bon moment voilà ce que dit la
boxeuse tcm bat je n'ai pas un modèle
juste un bon coup de pied à la fatalité
les intempéries la nuit dernière sur le
sud ouest de la france de violents
orages ont frappé le tarn et garonne
près de montauban des arbres sont tombés
sur des maisons 5 familles ont dû être
relogées sinding boudaoud la nuit
dernière a été rude pour beaucoup
d'habitants du tarn et garonne les
orages ont causé d'importants dégâts
comme ici dans ce lotissement de montech
près de montauban
plusieurs familles ont dû être relogées
provisoirement les pompiers du
département n'ont pas chômé ils sont
intervenus 130 fois pour porter
assistance à la population et pour
dégager les routes
nous avons des renforts de quatre
centres de secours pour aider dans notre
mission qui est principalement juste
monde toujours la même et re bâcher les
toitures
des voitures ont été abîmées par des
chutes d'arbres mais aucune victime
n'est signalé la violence des orages à
effrayer certains habitants on a passé
la nuit debout va supporter alors croire
la meilleure à les soutenir c'est que
les arbres obstruent le canal des deux
mers sur 7 km la circulation fluviale ne
devrait pas reprendre avant une bonne
semaine les cultures ont également
beaucoup souffert des orages
les dégâts n'ont pas encore été estimé
ce matin l'électricité a été rétablie
dans la plupart des foyers du secteur
touché hier soir par les intempéries
une nouvelle priorité pour lutter contre
la mort sur les routes le gouvernement
et les opérateurs de téléphonie mobile
ont lancé aujourd'hui une campagne de
sensibilisation sur les risques du
portable au volant
le nombre de conducteurs pris en faute a
augmenté de 10% l'an passé nicolas
lemarignier thierry breton ça en général
c'est plutôt mauvais signe
et cette fois pour ce contrôle de police
en plein coeur de paris
il est question de téléphone ce jour
merci
nous interpellons 6h téléphone portable
tenu à main gauche
au feu rouge comme en roulant le
téléphone portable est interdite au
volant pour cette infraction
l'automobiliste va perdre deux points
sur son permis et il devra payer une
amende de 22 euros sous trois jours
seul le kit main libre est toléré et
encore ça dépend du bon vouloir de la
jean bart à une application stricte d'un
texte précis l'article r 412-6 du code
de la route
il précise que tout conducteur doit se
tenir constamment en état et en position
d'exécuter commodément et sans délai
toutes les manoeuvres qui lui incombent
de nombreuses études scientifiques ont
montré que l'utilisation du portable
perturbe la conduite la vigilance
diminue le risque d'accident est
multiplié par quatre on n'est pas maître
véhicule on est distrait on est attentif
et en 2005 423 me automobilistes ont été
verbalisés parce qu'il téléphonait au
volant des statistiques en augmentation
pour les accros du portable la solution
la moins coûteuse c'est peut-être encore
de téléphoner en marchant toujours à
propos de santé publique le nouveau
credo des psychologues la quête de
l'estiment de soi la notion est ancienne
mais elle est maintenant au coeur des
thérapies les premiers livres sur le
sujet sont apparues il ya quelques
années en france ils ont fait un tabac
aujourd'hui dans le sport dans
l'entreprise et dans la vie courante
tout est fait pour renforcer la
confiance
l'amour propre c'est le dossier de cette
édition il est signé josé blanc lapierre
marque de langenhagen
quatre tours du monde en solitaire en
voilà une qui en a de l'audace et du
cran sa recette n'avoir jamais entendu
tu n'y arriveras pas je crois que j'ai
quand même un gros capital confiance et
que j'ai pas peur en fait c'est ça la
chose j'ai pas peur de faire j'ai pas
peur de me casser la figure
je sais que je vais survivre même si ce
que je fais ça rate tout ce que je fais
réussit pas pendant longtemps michel
s'est trouvé nul nul au point de ne pas
pouvoir affronter le regard des autres
si peu d estime d'elle-même qu'elles
n'osaient plus sortir faire ses courses
ni même prendre le bus qu'elle regardait
passer sans trouver la force de monter
j'avais rendez-vous quelconque affaire
par exemple c'était vraiment me dire ça
va être ça va être automatiquement raté
je vais faire un tel truc je vais nulle
java relais ridicule
les autres sont mieux que moi michel
sombrer dans la déprime
autour d'elle aucune compréhension
surtout pas celle de son mari elle m'a
fait encore baisser mon estime de moi ce
que je me disais tout le temps il a
peut-être raison après touche cette
femme en une cela s'appelle le cercle
vicieux de l'échec point de départ je
suis nul j'ai peur d'échouer
donc je préfère ne pas essayer mais je
n'obtiens pas ce que je veux alors je me
le reproche et je me confirme à quel
point je suis nul
michel revit elle a appris à s'accepter
grâce à une psychothérapie en deux temps
exercice pratique et théorie pour
chasser les pensées négatives poser des
limites ne pas chercher le parfait tout
le temps aidant tout est accepté qu'on
ne maîtrise pas tout on va partout
réussir et que quand je fais une erreur
ça ne veut pas dire que je ne suis pas
une personne malade sa c'est une plaie
importante
souvent ces gens là se disent tu as fait
une erreur donc tu es nul je leur dis
non les gens très bien en droit de faire
une erreur
champion du monde champion d'europe et
peu de place pour le doute mais pour
l'un des plus beaux palmarès du football
la confiance en soi cela ce travail ma
tête est comme un ordinateur
je suis rentré plein plein de choses à
l'intérieur ou aux techniques au niveau
du football à je pars au niveau du
football donc à l'entraînement je
travaille beaucoup
des ballons qui viennent de la droite
mais valenciennes de la gauche qui
viennent dans chaque position comme
comme cela quand il ya un moment de
doute
tout de suite j'ai une réponse j'ai moi
il s'agit d'affaires s'ajuste à fait oui
je sais faire
et au travail une mauvaise estime de soi
c'est ne pas savoir dire non un nom que
nathalie apprentis ci a formulé en face
d'elle un coach autrement dit une
professionnelle de la communication lui
explique comment dans une situation
donnée aboutir à s'imposer du ventre
quand on me solliciter pour un point d'y
faire aux travaux vont accepter tout le
temps que soit la charge de travail et
maintenant je refusais en fait le but de
ces séances est de faire prendre
conscience à nathalie qu'en fait elle a
toujours le choix soit tout accepter
soit se positionner par rapport à une
tâche donnée et j'ai refusé
chez quelqu'un qui ne s'est pas exposé
une demande et qui se trouve dans une
situation difficile qui peut pas en
sortir et qui sans faire dans cette
situation difficile par manque d'estimé
de soi parfois tout simplement parce que
les gens n'osent pas demander ce dont
ils ont besoin et qui n'est pas une
demande complètement aberrante fait ça
peut créer des situations de blocage
voire des conflits
quant à l'ex aide estime de soi poussé
jusqu'à la caricature
il fait rire j'ai toujours du bien de
moi au zoo c'est vrai dire du mal des
soldes c'est idiot fait leur donner des
idées qui n'auraient pas eu vraiment du
talent pendant les gens qui ont une
confiance on eu trop à affirmer d'abord
je trouve ça cache quelque chose
quand on est trop sûr de soi et puis je
passe enfin moi personnage je vais plus
à l'est vers quelqu'un qui voit là qui a
pas peur de montrer ses failles qui en
tient qu un doute
et puis surtout à voir rire de soi-même
c'est lundi d'une estime de soi et se
porte bien à l'étranger nouvelle épreuve
pour les états unis en irak les corps
des deux soldats enlevés la semaine
dernière ont été retrouvés ils ont été
torturés égorgés abandonné un carrefour
enlèvement revendiqué par la branche
irakienne d'al qaïda
alain chevron aaron diamond à washington
huit mille hommes mobilisés dans tout le
triangle sunnite
une des plus grosses opérations de
recherches depuis le début de la guerre
en irak pour retrouver les deux soldats
enlevés vendredi soir près de
youssoufiyah une course contre la montre
perdu les forces de la coalition ont
retrouvé ce que nous pensons être les
restes de nos deux soldats confirmation
peu après sur un site d'al qaïda je cite
nous annonçons la bonne nouvelle les
deux croisés ont été exécutés par
égorgement
fin de citation les deux cadavres
portaient des traces de torture
l'égorgeur pourrait être al masri le
nouveau chef d'al-qaïda en personne le
successeur de zarqawi mort il ya une
douzaine de jours le cap des 2500
soldats américains morts en irak a été
passé la semaine dernière et aujourd'hui
deux familles de plus sont dans la
douleur et réclament vengeance non oui
j'espère qu'on va leur faire payer pour
ce qu'ils ont fait est tout de suite
plutôt que de les garder en prison pour
toujours
après la mort de zarqawi l'ennemi numéro
un des états unis en irak gens je bouge
pensait pouvoir ouvrir une nouvelle page
de cette guerre c'était oublier que dans
ce pays les mauvaises nouvelles
succèdent très vite aux bonnes par
ailleurs le japon a décidé
officiellement de retirer ses troupes
d'irak d'ici cinq semaines 600 hommes se
consacre essentiellement à des tâches
humanitaires
une date importante pour la justice
internationale l'ex dictateur du liberia
charles taylor vient d'arriver aux pays
bas après slobodan milosevic il sera le
deuxième chef d'état à être jugé pour
crimes de guerre et crimes contre
l'humanité
charles taylor 58 ans est considéré
comme l'un des principaux responsables
des terribles guerre civile en sierra
leone et au liberia
puis 15 ans là-bas en sierra leone
beaucoup s'en souviennent le pays compte
un nombre record d'amputer il faut dire
que les combattants prenaient un malin
plaisir à mutiler les populations
civiles depuis la fin des combats un
club de football
unique en son genre a fait son
apparition envoyés spéciaux à freetown
dominique derda frédéric guiraud
coiffeur pour lui ça n'a jamais été une
vocation juste un travail façon comme
une autre de s'en sortir quand on est
assez habile de ses mains en sierra
leone ce n'est déjà pas si mal
je suis content de travailler et même si
je ne gagne pas grand chose au moins je
ne suis pas dans la rue en train de
mendier dans ce pays ravagé par dix
années de guerre civile tout le monde
connaît maxwell fornas non pas parce
qu'il est le meilleur coiffeur de la
capitale et parce qu'il est l'attaquant
vedette de l'équipe de football des
unijambistes lui c'est en 2001 qu'il a
perdu ça change une balle dans le genou
la gangrène qui menaçait il a fallu
couper au club il ya ce qui pousse le
ballon à cloche pied et dans les buts
les manchots ce sont les rebelles qui
l'auront tranché le bras manches longues
ou mange pour 17 ans à l'époque en
fonction de la hauteur à laquelle sa
passe était la machette des
tortionnaires tous en choeur c'est bien
qu'on fasse quelque chose comme ça les
gens voient qu'on n'est pas des bons
arrive qu'on peut encore être utile
c'est pour ça que je fais du sport
selon les estimations il y aurait entre
cinq et dix mille amputé en sierra leone
sur 5 million et demi d'habitants c'est
bouclé ceux qui jouent au football comme
maxwell ne sont qu'une minorité une
centaine au grand maximum
mais ils sont et de loin les plus
déterminés au centre d'appareillage et
de rééducation de handicap international
sur les hauteurs de freetown
on sait bien que réparer les corps ne
suffit pas il faut surtout soigner les
esprits le football on les aime d'abord
à développer leur musculature
ça les aide surtout psychologiquement à
surmonter leur traumatisme
et ça c'est une très bonne chose dans
les salles obscures où l'on
retransmettent en direct les matchs de
la coupe du monde
ils sont parmi les spectateurs les plus
assidus et tous sans exception rêve d'un
destin à l'image de celui d'un pauleta
ou d'un flic ou moins tôt l'année
prochaine on va organiser ici la coupe
d'afrique des clubs d'unijambiste où
j'espère que quelqu'un me verra jouer et
me proposera de passer professionnel
l'an dernier déjà grâce à l'argent d'un
généreux donateur ils se sont rendus au
brésil participé à leur premier tournoi
international
ils ont fini troisièmes un triomphe
alors depuis tous les espoirs sont
permis car s'il manque de tout de
chaussures de maillots de ballons
maxwell et ses coéquipiers ont du
courage et de l'énergie à rauzan on en
vient maintenant la coupe du monde
l'équipe de france a repris
l'entraînement aujourd'hui et une fois
n'est pas coutume les supporters ont eu
droit à une longue visite des joueurs
autographes et embrassades notamment
pour thuram et makelele arn envoyés
spéciaux manuel tissier vincent
bouffartigue
dans leur forteresse darden les bleus
ont accordé un ticket d'entrée
aujourd'hui une poignée de supporters
récompensés de leur patience et d'un
long voyage
claude makelele est un lilian thuram
très détendus ont ouvert une petite
brèche dans le strict règlement du
château il a insisté pour venir nous
voir au frais la sécurité donc c'était
sympathique
il faut y aller vendredi c'est faux tout
donné le choix les 23 se sont séparés
cet après-midi les titulaires dans le
parc pour des exercices légers les
autres sur la pelouse voisine
raymond domenech a mélangé les
remplaçants de dimanche avec des jeunes
d'un club de hanovre
les suspensions de zidane et abidal vont
changer la donne contre le togo alors
les entraîneurs cherchent la bonne
formule mais malgré les doutes les bleus
restent en position de force dans leur
groupe
est ce que c'est une position de force
ou de faiblesse je sais pas on verra
près parce qu'on peut être tétanisé
aussi des impôts absolument gagner 2-0
en common laborde
on va l'abordage on se fait prendre en
compte s'il y a il ya un dialogue commun
qu'il faut vraiment mettre en place pour
pour pour avancer l'équipe de france est
dans le même cas de figure qu'il ya
quatre ans avant son troisième match
contre le danemark
mais à trois jours de ce rendez vous
crucial pour son avenir
il reste encore l'espoir de prolonger
l'avanture dans la campagne allemande
les résultats maintenant hier l'espagne
a rejoint les qualifiés pour les
huitièmes de finale après sa victoire
face à la tunisie
aujourd'hui nouvelle victoire de
l'allemagne qui impressionne 3 0 face à
l'équateur christophe du chien au début
on aurait pu leur pré tient à pikine
mois nous mais maintenant c'est terminé
avec l'appétit qui vient en gagnant les
allemands caresse le rêve de plus en
plus fort avec l'espoir de poser bientôt
une quatrième coupe du monde dans la
vitrine
les deux équipes avaient en commun
d'être qualifié pour le tour prochain
mais en termes de suprématie allemand
équatorien ne font pas la paire comme
titi et grosminet quatre minutes de jeu
closer à 0 auteur du but
il s'en tire par une pirouette après un
quart d'heure de jeu
klose et marque encore ce qui fait lui
pour l'instant le meilleur buteur de la
coupe du monde avec 4 buts 2 à 0 c'est
le score au repos
pas vraiment le genre de match qui vole
haut sauf quand valencia tacle
l'allemand ballack ce qui lui vaudra un
carton jaune comme son maillot alors
qu'à rouge comme ses chaussettes et
comme l'expulsion valait la peine de
faire de la deuxième période podolski va
ajouté un troisième but au terme d'une
contre attaque rondement mené une équipe
de jeunes qui marque des buts et qui a
enthousiasmé son public
mon voisin de la chance trois victoires
premier du groupe c'était hier soir il
faudrait pas s'égarer
les artistes se sont d'abord les joueurs
mais parfois le technicien de terrain
aussi est un homme de spectacle à la
matière roger lemerre l'entraîneur
français des tunisiens déçoit rarement
sur son expression artistique
pour ce qui est de la note technique les
tunisiens marque face à l'espagne après
neuf minutes de jeu grâce à marie
belote et rebelote en deuxième période
projet s'excite s'énerve s'en va
laissant porte et puis en 20 minutes
funeste par trois fois les ibères
s'acharne contre les tunisiens qui
s'incline finalement 3 1 à la fin on
aurait dit toute la pluie tombée sur la
tête de roger en tout cas ce nouveau
succès allemand on va renforcer
l'engouement local pour la compétition
personne n'avait imaginé un tel succès
ils étaient 700 milles tout à l'heure
dans les rues de berlin
jérôme baugnies marine main sans les 14
100 cols blancs dossier masse à berlin
ont fermé les bureaux à 15h30 cet après
midi les paris allaient bon train
c'est évident une victoire 3 1 pour
l'allemagne
ça se voit non dit magna ou là la
direction a même mis les petits plats
dans les grands pour cette pause
sportive y contribue à entretenir
l'esprit d'entreprise
bien sûr nous avons maintenu quelques
postes dans les cas d'urgence
mais le plus important c'est de fêter
cet événement tous ensemble et
l'ambiance y est et le premier but pour
ses employés qui font les 38 heures ce
cadeau de deux heures de détente est
aussi une façon de faire tomber les
cloisons entre bureaux de fêter ensemble
est de reconnaître qu'ils évitent à ce
qu'on ne voit pas qu'on n'a pas
l'occasion de voir si souvent fait tout
berlin qui est en liesse
ils sont plus de 400 milles sur la
fameuse avenue des fans on a même sorti
le casque à pointe comme symbole de la
plus ancienne mais pour l'immense
majorité il s'agit de patriotisme bon
enfant pas de nationalisme
inde où des dizaines de millions de
supporteurs ont encore une fois livré
avec cette troisième victoire de leur
équipe nationale
un dernier résultat cet après-midi la
pologne s'est imposé pour la gloire face
au costa rica 2 buts à 1
les deux équipes sont de toute façon
éliminée elle l'était déjà avant le
début de la rencontre elles vont rentrer
à la maison fin de ce journal merci
d'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
patrice drevet 20h50 un film l'amour en
douce avec emmanuelle béart et daniel
auteuil
à demain